hey guys it is Friday again which means
I've got five is this week's very best
stories in Geylang all ready to go for
you here's the cool stuff that happens
first up a Colorado Springs man has
fulfilled many gamers fantasies by
shooting the crap out of his computer
Lucas hinge took his dell XPS 410 into a
back alley and shot at eight times with
a 9-millimeter handgun the 37-year old
man reported that he was frustrated
after repeatedly receiving blue screens
of death the police report entitled man
kills his computer notice of the man's
attack resulted in quotes effectively
disabling the PSD as the hinge he said
the shooting was glorious following that
up with a comment that quote Angel's son
on high
next up Frederick meet co-founder of the
Pirate Bay has been denied an NES in
prison a Swedish news publication has
reported that needs is request was
denied due to those in charge insisting
they could not check the interior of the
console for contraband without breaking
it eh has noted that seeing as the
device has no online functionality it
probably shouldn't be perceived as a
threat and a simple screwdriver would be
pretty effective at breaking open the
system without causing damage this
weekend things getting cheaper if you
live in the UK now it's a good time to
think about picking yourself up a ps4
just a little over a week after the xbox
one was discounted to 300 pounds the ps4
has now been hit with its own price cut
Sony's newest console is now discounted
to 290 pounds down from 330 the deal
appears to be available on sites
including Tesco amazon and Argos
although sony has said the promotion
will end on April 28 sony has rolled out
a minor system update for the ps4 and
people have been going nuts about it for
some reason the 2.51 update which landed
a few days ago came to 245 megabytes and
has implemented minor fixes including
System Shock West ability during the use
of some features as well as an
improvements to operations quality for
some applications unfortunately one bugs
that users discovered in March which
pushes a rest mode notification pop up
when the console is turned on has not
been fixed
finally Microsoft have landed in some
hot water this week after allegedly
passing off some Witcher 3 footage as
being captured on Xbox one when it was
actually done flow on PCs Microsoft's
posted the lovely looking clip up on
their xbox youtube channel a couple of
days ago while it wasn't explicitly
stated that the footage was captured on
xbox one the video did prominently
feature the Xbox logo and there was no
disclaimer indicating the footage was
taken from the pc version until a few
hours after it was published kotaku
discovered the origin of the footage due
to the fact that the video plays at
1080p and 60fps whereas the xbox one
version of The Witcher 3 only clocks in
at a maximum of nine hundred p and 30
FPS microsoft absence apologize for the
confusion and so they didn't intend to
misrepresent the visual fidelity of the
xbox one version let me know what you
can about this week and if you've ever
felt the urge to shoot your computer and
why this week on slide I run down the
difference between DLC and expansion
packs on the gist in two minutes tops
controversial character redesigns and we
discuss the gameplay of star wars
battlefront on the lobby that's it from
me this week as always thanks for tuning
in and be sure to have yourself an
awesome weekend